[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is oneplus 5t
it is
literally the 2017 eyes version of the
oneplus 5.
now the oneplus 5 just came out in june
of this year so it's only a couple
months old and oneplus is a company that
tends to cater to what their fans want
that phone had a lot going for it but it
just didn't feel very 2017 with all the
other phones coming out but this
this now we're talking so in case maybe
you looked over the oneplus 5 a couple
months ago this is their new one maybe
you'll consider this is the top five new
features of the brand new oneplus 5t so
number one is the display and this is
definitely the biggest change literally
it's what makes it feel the most like a
new phone it's now a six inch 1080p
amoled display up front and it gets way
closer to every edge so the side bezels
are slimmer now and the top and bottom
bezels are cut down a lot obviously
that's very 2017. you already know
screen to body ratio matters now and
this feels a lot more modern already
because of it now it's still not a quad
hd display it's not quite at the level
of the highest end flagships in
resolution but oneplus also likes to
stick with the lower resolution for
longer as they have in the name of
battery life and performance and 1080p
obviously doesn't look bad at all so i
get it also if you haven't noticed it is
the new longer taller two to one aspect
ratio we're seeing on all these 2017
phones so this one's 2160 by 1080. it's
not new to android so apps already fill
up the display and everything there's no
real compatibility problems but still of
course it gives you a bit of bezel when
watching videos and things like that but
we're just kind of used to this by now
on these screens bottom line is the
display is way better it definitely gets
really bright so it's viewable outdoors
and it has different color modes in the
settings including an adjustment slider
for color temperature so they've thought
of all this stuff but you're probably
not going to like this though it is an
oled and the display does this weird
rainbowing when you get severely off
axis not a huge deal to everyone but i
can already see this awkwardly making
some headlines so number two is oneplus
sticking to their guns with this design
we have definitely seen this industrial
unibody metal look before
there are some chamfers and some light
curves but overall it's the shape we're
familiar with it resembles its little
brother a lot but there are a couple of
changes obviously with this nearly edge
to edge display of course on the front
there's no longer any room for that
fingerprint sensor that they've always
put up there so this is the first
oneplus phone to move it to the back and
they have put it in what i'd consider
the correct place on the back which is
just above the middle not too high not
too low just right about where your
finger rests naturally it's still
ceramic it's still extremely fast uh
still just as secure but it's on the
back now like where it's been with the
pixel and the v30 and others nice and
something else that's usually pretty
underrated with smartphones is good
buttons in fact we usually don't really
talk about them at all unless they're
loose bad buttons so i feel the need to
mention that the oneplus 5t has
exceptionally good really clicky
convincing crisp tactile buttons i like
that about it and another thing oneplus
has never officially said that the 5t or
the 5 is officially water resistant or
waterproof but i've seen some videos on
youtube where the 5 holds up pretty well
to some minor splashing so that could be
a nice bonus to something you usually
don't hear about with this industrial
design now number three is what oneplus
has decided to do with these cameras so
the oneplus 5 already had dual cameras
it had a main camera and a two times
telephoto lens on the back pretty
standard setup from what we've seen but
this time they've decided to do some
things a little different this time it's
the same 16 megapixel main camera as the
oneplus 5 but instead of a second
telephoto lens it's another normal range
camera same focal length 20 megapixels
but with an f 1.7 lens focused on low
light photography now here's the thing
about that the main camera
is already an f 1.7 lens and it's less
pixels so they're bigger pixels so you
would think that's also better for low
light so how exactly is this second
camera better for low light well oneplus
says that the 5t in low light so under
10 lux will switch automatically to that
second camera and use something called
intelligent pixel technology which
merges four pixels into one
to reduce noise and enhance clarity in
low light i can't find a better
explanation than what oneplus says i'm
not sure if it's hardware specific i
would love to know exactly how it works
but at this point we just kind of trust
it i hope it works the way they say it
does there's also still portrait mode in
these cameras using all software to
create a blur around your subject since
you don't have a telephoto lens anymore
it's kind of like what the pixel 2 is
doing they still have clear zoom and pro
mode and all the other stuff oneplus has
been doing in the camera for years so
that's good to see but yeah an
interesting little shake up in the
camera department and then number four a
new way to log into this phone is their
new facial recognition there's not a
whole lot of information about this
available but from what i can tell you
from my first impressions it is
insanely fast
five ten times faster than face id on
the iphone it's ridiculous so you can
hit the power button to wake up the
phone and basically turn it towards you
as soon as it sees your face it unlocks
no animation or anything just open
immediately and then even if you're
already looking at your phone when you
take it out your pocket and you press
the power button to wake it just goes
straight to your home screen it doesn't
even pause for a second on your lock
screen to look at you
which it's crazy fast it could actually
get annoying if you just wanted to check
your notifications so obviously it's
brand new and this isn't a full review i
will definitely have to do some more
testing to figure out if this is the
real deal but my first thought is how
can this be so fast and also be just as
secure not really sure yet but either
way it's really interesting to see some
phone makers already start to play
around with more facial recognition
stuff now that apple of course is so
committed to it with iphone x and then
number five last but not least is
the stuff they didn't change one plus
five like i've said already was a pretty
great phone for the price they're really
hell bent on being a good phone for the
price so they kept a lot of those same
things in the oneplus 5t they kept the
headphone jack that's something a lot of
enthusiasts refused to let die so this
is one of your few phones left rocking
it this year they kept the alert slider
on the side again i mean if you've used
oneplus phones for a while you kind of
just get used to having this and
switching between modes on the fly they
kept of course oxygen os which is the
rom that's always been pretty close to
stock android with a few added features
on top still has that shelf to the side
of the home screen and those gestures
for screen off that you can draw on the
screen just overall a familiar
experience for oneplus users right now
it's on top of android 7.1.1 but i
expect that it'll get updated to oreo
sooner than later it kept the same specs
internally as the oneplus 5 so still the
snapdragon 835 chip and either 64 with 6
gigs of ram or 128 with 8 gigs of ram no
wireless charging still but they kept
dash charging kept reader mode and most
importantly of all it's keeping around
that same price it's starting at 499
which is very clearly undercutting a lot
of the higher end flagships we've seen
in the last couple months so uh this
might be the one oneplus 5 felt a little
outdated this 5t feels very 2017 and
still costs less than a lot of the
others out there not bad let me know
what you guys think until the next one
thank you for watching talk to you later
peace
[Music]